high startup school founders I am Jeff
Ralston ycs president and I'm here to
say so long and to give a few words of
parting advice it's after 10:00
extraordinary weeks of startup school we
here at YC are about to focus on our
winter 2020 batch and you all will be
off working on your startups hopefully
we'll see many of you at interviews for
winter 2020 and no matter what you'll
all continue working on your startups
regardless of what happens with YC here
are a few things to think about as you
enter this next phase of your company
it's so easy to be distracted by what's
happening with other startups it's a
great thing to be part of a community of
startups so this is the one thing you
have to be careful about and to remember
is that every startup every single one
has a different path every founder has a
different path when I first came to
Silicon Valley to work for the venerable
company hewlett-packard as a coder I
dreamed of starting a start-up we used
to go drinking Friday nights and talk
about well drinking was the important
part and talking about startups was the
second most important part but that's
what we did we always talked about what
our path would be what our founder path
would be but we had no idea how to go
about it pg hadn't started Y Combinator
yet we couldn't go online to ask basic
questions about how to start a startup
actually there wasn't even an online
back then venture capitalists were these
mysterious suits who only would talk to
MBAs we didn't know where to go it
actually took me 12 years to find my
path to start my startup and that was my
path and it worked out
but everything's different now thanks
largely to Paul there's so much help I
hope that YC startup school has been
transformational for you guys for your
companies and for your future I hope
you've learned enough focused enough
launched enough to make a difference to
make a difference that will put your
startup on a path to success that path
will be different for everyone when I
finally gave up my job gave up working
for the man and began to search for my
future startup I came to build web-based
email later that was purchased by Yahoo
and that's where I met peih-gee and his
co-founder Trevor at their company via
Web
before starting YC Paul spent tons of
time doing other things he wrote he
painted before he found his next path
Trevor
moved out to California funded his own
hardware startup to build robots
whatever your path find it make it yours
and you do this by focusing on the
important things focus on what matters
focus on what you've learned at startup
school stay connected with the community
use the updates use the forum talk to
people most importantly as you've heard
again and again make something that
people want and as you do that as you
make something people want measure it
keep track of your progress make sure
you know where your value is added hire
incredible people surround yourself with
the best of the best and that will give
you the best chance to build an epic
company and don't give up focus on
making a company that is healthy and
happy and moving forward always we say
this all the time at Y Combinator
startups are hard
the books written about startups talk
about how hard they are well there's no
easy decisions it's hard and it's
all-consuming and it's the most
wonderful thing in the world
PG wrote an essay where he quoted a
founder saying it's surprising how much
you become consumed by your startup you
think about it day and night but it
never does feel like work however one of
the constants of startups is that things
will go wrong things will go wrong with
your startup they always do it's almost
the beauty of startups and you guys are
the problem solvers in chief the times I
remember the most
when I was at startups or where things
went wrong and we found solutions even
when I was by myself when I quit HP to
start a startup I was lost I didn't know
what to do until I realized I needed to
make something and I started coding and
I started talking to customers in that
startup that Yahoo bought for one one
some of the problems we ran into were
earth-shattering and it looked like it
was the end of the company some we just
thought were like that we thought if our
site ever went down that would be the
end of the company we had to be the most
reliable service on the internet so we
had all of our own servers in our office
everything was right there and that was
great until the power went out no we had
thought of that eventuality and we had
Universal power supplies huge batteries
really big ones the last four hours but
this power outage in particular that I'm
thinking of went on and on it lasted and
lasted and lasted after six hours we
were shutting things down to preserve
electricity we kept the core service up
but then the UPS has started to beep
saying we had a very short time left
almost simultaneously the lights went on
but not in our office across the parking
lot the line where they had brought
power back
was directly next door but our power
actually wouldn't come on for another
six hours so we solved the problem we
got a really long extension cord I
happen to have a little plug you could
screw into a light bulb we plug the cord
in and stayed up and never went down I
don't know if that was an existential
problem but we solved it another thing I
remember is when I was running a company
called Lala which was a music company
this company built a great product
people loved it and it was so good that
Facebook actually chose us to be
Facebook music this was a huge deal this
was company making or as it turned out
nearly company breaking because we
worked on that deal for six months six
months the most complex deal I've ever
been involved with we negotiated with
Facebook we negotiated with every single
music label with every single music
publisher we crafted this deal we were
almost at the finish line maybe a week
or two or three away and Luck cancelled
the whole deal our company had focused
exclusively on this for so long we were
lost but we didn't give up after that we
might have but we refocused we built new
services we did a deal with Google we
did another deal with Facebook and six
months later we were purchased by Apple
for almost a hundred million dollars
which in the music industry is pretty
good we have so many stories like this
at YC a founders overcoming adversity
with determination grit resourcefulness
the canonical story that YC is of course
the Airbnb founders who actually made
cereal and sold it to survive they have
other stories where there was a disaster
in one of their rentals and how they
responded to that turned the company
actually from a real negative into a
positive there's so many of these
stories that I can think of there's a
company that was a high-flyer was doing
incredible with
selling so many so much of their goods
mostly from China that they were one of
our most popular one one of our most
valuable companies and then all of a
sudden China shut the door closed off
the trade killed their business and the
founder had to personally lay off
hundreds of people he sat in on every
single layoff he went through trauma
that was hard to describe but he
survived and came through the other side
and that company is once again thriving
there's another company I like to think
about this great founder team we really
like both the founder he had a close
friend as a as a team member but right
before they started YC something went
wrong something went wrong between them
the co-founder quit an old friend and
actually sued the company we had to push
back and say look you're not ready for
YC now he had to deal with a really
traumatic situation with a lawsuit from
a friend didn't have a lot of cash had
to pay out to make it go away but
surprisingly really showing the kind of
grit that really makes for great
founders he came back he did a
subsequent batch and that company now
has millions of dollars in the bank
millions of dollars in revenue and is
doing fantastic these are the stories
that you'll remember these are the tests
that tests whether you're you have the
ability to create an epic company in the
future so what do you do when you're in
this situation well my simple answer is
always default to action right code talk
to users that's what we did at Lala
we went back at our core product and
made it better you see this all the time
things go disastrously wrong at a
start-up and the founders get sad and
sad this leads to inaction it leads to
apathy it leads to depression don't do
that don't get sad go do write code talk
to users make your product better always
make for
word progress Sam Altman the president
before me always used to say be
ambitious this is the time to think big
when things are the worst make progress
take chances
if you can stay default alive because
that way you can survive through
everything
keep profitability within reach whenever
profit whatever possible and keep going
all of these are simple way of saying to
whatever extent you can keep control of
your own destiny lastly I want to
encourage you to think about the kind of
company you're building and why you're
building it aspire to create an epic
organization that will outlast you
interpret this quote from PG don't just
be evil be good
broadly benevolence will pay you back
this is not neutral this isn't just
idealism this will actually make your
company better more more likely to
succeed more powerful PG wrote an essay
about this and you should read it where
he talks about my help you get when your
benevolent how you improve company's
morale HAP how you actually can create a
power equation that makes your company
more successful and being good as I said
you should think about broadly be good
and kind to yourself eat well exercise
stay in control of yourself in your
sanity because rolling back to what I
said earlier startups are hard really
hard be good to your co-founders one of
the main reasons that companies fail is
because co-founder relationships break
down and founding teams break up we
funded a company in the summer of 2015
called inner space which has a lot of
material on how to communicate well with
your co-founders so this doesn't happen
but likewise be good to your employees
be good to the people you work with
choose a culture and values that are
positive make your company a happy
exciting place to work you can always
feel that vibe if you go into a
successful company
go into a company with a hundred people
where they are moving and they are going
forward and they are creating something
special and you can feel it and of
course be good to your customers they
pay the bills they're the reason you do
what you do
being customer-centric is always a
recipe for success be good to your
investors they took a chance on you and
that will pay back in the future because
you never know when you're gonna raise
money again and lastly this matters so
much to us
at Y Combinator that's why we're here we
intrinsically believe that by working
with great founders like you all we make
the world a better place because you
guys make the world a world a better
place so be good for the world
so in summary find your path find your
own unique path to startup success you
do this by focusing on what matters and
by building something people want
remember things will go wrong they do go
wrong but be determined resourceful in
the face of adversity and you will
outlast those problems the best course
of action is action so default to it
default to action in action and a
startup is the death of the startup
don't be sad be determined and lastly be
good be kind and create the kind of
company that you would like to work at
so I hope your startup experience is
like mine the highlight of your
professional careers good luck thanks so
much for taking part in YC summer 2019
startup school and I hope to see you all
again soon
you